When I arrive at Margo's apartment for our interview--
当我为了采访来到玛戈的公寓时——
Come on in.
进来吧。
--she opens the door holding a glass of wine.
——她打开门，手里拿着一杯葡萄酒。
Hi. Oh, I need to have a glass of wine while I talk about my family.
嗨。哦，我谈论家人时需要喝杯酒。
This is not totally a joke. She's got 11 brothers and sisters, and yes, Catholics, old school, Irish mom, Italian immigrant dad. And the kids do not all get along.
这可不是完全在开玩笑。她有11个兄弟姐妹，没错，都是老派的天主教徒，爱尔兰裔母亲，意大利移民父亲。而且孩子们之间相处得并不融洽。
How many of your siblings do not speak with?
你的兄弟姐妹中有多少人不和你说话？
I don't speak to-- Eddie, Victor, Mary Jo, Marina, Nancy-- five.
我不和——埃迪、维克多、玛丽·乔、玛丽娜、南希这五个人说话。
You were counting on your fingers.
你在用手指头数呢。
Because I had to think.
因为我得想一想。
We sit down on the couch together. The living room is decked out for a Game of Thrones viewing party. And I mean, like seriously decked out, like 15 plastic swords stuck into the back of an older rattan chair to make a fake iron throne, a miniature weirwood tree. I have no idea where you get something like that. It's totally distracting. On the coffee table in front of us, she's gathered stuff for the interview.
我们一起坐在沙发上。客厅里装饰着《权力的游戏》观影派对的布置。我是说，非常隆重的布置，比如把15把塑料剑插在一张旧藤椅的靠背上做成假铁王座，还有一棵微缩的鱼梁木。我完全不知道她从哪弄来这些东西。这真的很让人分心。在我们面前的咖啡桌上，她摆好了采访用的东西。
There's a glass of white wine. What kind of wine?
那儿有一杯白葡萄酒。是什么酒？
Sauvignon Blanc.
长相思。
And there's a book. And there's a list. What is the list?
还有一本书。还有一个清单。那清单是什么？
This is the order of the items of the things, in the order that I would like them from my parents' estate.
这是我希望从父母遗产中获得物品的顺序清单。
Her parents' estate, that's what I'm here to talk to her about. When her parents died, her dad, in 2006, her mom, two years ago, they didn't specify in their wills which child would get which items. No, no, no-- they left all that to the kids, saying simply, everyone should get an equal amount.
她父母的遗产，这就是我来采访她的目的。她父母去世时，父亲于2006年去世，母亲两年前去世，他们在遗嘱中并没有具体说明哪个孩子该得到哪件东西。不，不，不——他们把一切都留给了孩子们，只是简单地说，每个人都应该得到等值的遗产。
Sibling number eight in the birth order, Joe, a lawyer, the sunny one in the family, was the sibling left with the truly thankless task of dividing the stuff. Their parents were these imposing, brilliant people, who they still talk about in this worshipful way.
家中排行第八的乔，是个律师，也是家里性格最阳光的孩子，被留下来处理分配这些东西的苦差事。他们的父母是那种令人敬畏、才华横溢的人，孩子们至今仍以一种崇拜的方式谈论他们。
What they have left to them is just these things, right? And this mandate-- to get along well enough one last time to split it up amongst themselves. And they don't want to screw it up. They want to honor their parents' last request. But they know it's going to be tough for them, given how they are sometimes with each other.
留给他们的只有这些东西，对吧？还有这个使命——最后一次和睦相处，把它们平分。他们不想搞砸。他们想尊重父母最后的遗愿。但他们知道这会很艰难，考虑到他们平时互相之间的样子。
So they invented a process that is so elaborate, honestly, I found it kind of shocking, impressive but extreme. It includes the book, the one on the coffee table that Joe had created. It's thick and spiral bound, with photos of all 196 items of the parents that are up for grabs. Each item gets a number.
于是他们发明了一个非常复杂的流程，老实说，我觉得既令人震惊又印象深刻，但有点极端。其中包括那本书，就是乔制作的放在咖啡桌上的那一本。它很厚，是螺旋装订的，里面有父母留下的196件待分配物品的照片。每件物品都有一个编号。
He's given a lot of thought to it. And there's four pages of rules and regulations of what you have to do.
他为此做了很多考量。而且有四页关于你必须怎么做的规章制度。
Actually, it's five pages of rules, single spaced, 23 rules. Here's number 10.
其实是五页规则，单倍行距，一共23条。这是第10条。
Number 10, the estate is not recognizing any alleged oral promises by mommy or daddy to give certain items to certain distributees. Thus, all such items are available to be selected. Hard, documented proof is required to show that intent and to exclude an item from the selection process. Thus far--
第10条，遗产分配不承认父母对某些受赠人做出的所谓口头承诺。因此，所有此类物品均可供选择。必须提供确凿的证明文件，才能将某件物品排除在选择程序之外。迄今为止——
Notice how every I is being dotted here. Hard not to wonder what mommy and daddy would think of it. The kids so suspicious of each other that all this would be necessary. The mom's engagement ring, for example.
注意看每一处细节是如何界定的。很难不去想父母会怎么看这一切。孩子们对彼此的怀疑竟然到了这种地步。以母亲的订婚戒指为例。
To prove to anybody who might doubt that this is actually her ring, the one that she wore when they were little kids, and her whole life, until the viewing at her funeral, there's a photo they took of the ring being handed from the funeral director over to one of the brothers, who then took it to a jeweler, who certified that it is, in fact, the original diamond.
为了向任何怀疑这是否真是她戒指的人证明——这枚戒指是他们小时候，乃至她一生中一直佩戴的，直到葬礼瞻仰仪式——他们拍了一张照片，记录了戒指从殡仪馆主任手中转交给其中一个兄弟的过程，然后他把它带去珠宝商那里，鉴定出这确实是原始钻石。
But the siblings that I talked to agreed all this is necessary, because there are definite camps among the siblings. Depending on the issue, they break down into two general teams.
但我采访的兄弟姐妹们都认为这一切是有必要的，因为兄弟姐妹中确实存在明显的派系。根据议题，他们大致分为两个阵营。
Do the two sides have a name that we should be using?
这两方有我们应该使用的名字吗？
No.
没有。
OK, how should we refer to them?
好吧，我们该怎么称呼他们？
Oh, we can refer to them as the Rockaway crew versus the non Rockaway crew.
哦，我们可以称他们为洛克威（Rockaway）一派和非洛克威一派。
Because they're the people who basically stayed in the neighborhood, and the people who didn't.
因为他们分别是基本上留在那个社区的人，和没有留下来的人。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Rockaway, by the way, is a neighborhood on the water in Queens, New York. Margo is a non Rockaway. And in describing other non Rockaways, she says things like--
顺便说一下，洛克威是纽约皇后区水边的一个社区。玛戈是非洛克威派。在描述其他非洛克威派成员时，她说的话像——
Very handsome.
非常英俊。
Or perhaps--
或者也许是——
Generous, kind, brilliant, PhD.
慷慨、善良、才华横溢、博士。
But it's hard for Margo to even list the Rockaways without insulting them by the time she gets to the second person on the list.
但玛戈在列举洛克威派成员时，甚至很难不侮辱他们，往往提到名单上的第二个人的时候就开始了。
One of my brothers is an architect, and he lives in Rockaway. And another one is a lawyer-- eh, lawyer, after a few times at the bar. He--
我的一个兄弟是建筑师，住在洛克威。另一个是律师——呃，在酒吧喝了几次酒后的律师。他——
Margo and that brother have particularly bitter grudges against each other. But I will say, I have never done an interview with somebody who drops her voice so often and so happily in the middle of stories to gossip on the record about their family. It made her really fun to talk to.
玛戈和那个兄弟之间有着特别深重的积怨。但我得说，我从没采访过像她这样，在讲故事的过程中如此频繁且愉快地压低声音，公然八卦自己家人的采访对象。这让她变得非常有趣。
Margo explained that when they were kids, she and her siblings had normal rivalries that you would expect in any family that big. But then when their parents got old, adult disputes and adult resentments came up between them. Like for instance, who would get the house in Italy, where their dad was born.
玛戈解释说，当他们还是孩子时，她和兄弟姐妹们有着大家庭中预料之中的那种正常的竞争。但后来父母老了，成年人之间的纠纷和怨恨就在他们中间出现了。比如，谁该得到父亲出生地意大利的那栋房子。
It went to Mary Anne, the oldest kid, who'd fixed it up. Or whether Mary Ellen, the next to youngest, who for a while was responsible for their mom's care, was doing right by her. Sibling number five, Victor, thought he should be the one in charge of her care. Some of the Rockaways agreed, non Rockaways did not. And Victor stopped talking to a bunch of them, like permanently. Here's Victor.
房子给了老大玛丽·安，因为她负责修缮。又或者关于倒数第二个孩子玛丽·艾伦，她曾有一段时间负责照顾母亲，大家质疑她是否尽职。排行第五的维克多认为照顾母亲的事应该由他负责。一些洛克威派的人同意，非洛克威派的则不同意。于是维克多和他们中的一些人彻底断绝了联系。这是维克多。
Let's just say that I was disappointed in some of them, because I knew what was best for my mom. I visit my mother every day of my life, unless I was out of town. And after my father passed, I visit my mother twice a day. OK? And I bought my home one block from her house. So they had a choice. I thought they should have backed me.
只能说我对他们中的一些人感到失望，因为我知道什么对我妈妈最好。我每天都去看望母亲，除非我出城。父亲去世后，我一天看望母亲两次。好吗？而且我的房子就买在她家隔壁。所以他们本可以选择。我觉得他们应该支持我。
The bad feeling between the two sides bubbled over, even on the one day you'd think they'd put it to rest-- the day their mom died. Joe, the one who adjudicates between the non Rockaways and the Rockaways, was stuck in California, where he lives, that day.
双方之间的恶感即使在那个你以为他们会放下恩怨的一天——他们母亲去世的那天——也爆发了。乔，那个在非洛克威派和洛克威派之间进行裁决的人，那天被困在他居住的加利福尼亚州。
On the day my mother died, April 8, 2017, I was trying a case in San Diego. And I got the phone call from the nursing home, saying, excuse me, we have to hold your mother's body, because there are two funeral directors that have come to pick up the body.
在我母亲去世的那天，2017年4月8日，我正在圣地亚哥处理一起案件。我接到疗养院的电话，说，不好意思，我们得扣留你母亲的遗体，因为来了两家殡仪馆的人要来接遗体。
What happened is a few of the Rockaways had arranged for a funeral in Rockaway. And one of the non Rockaways had arranged a funeral at their mom's parish, out on Long Island.
发生的情况是，一些洛克威派的人安排在洛克威举行葬礼。而其中一名非洛克威派的人在他们母亲位于长岛的教区安排了另一场葬礼。
So that was my-- I spent three hours brokering a deal to have the funeral in Rockaway.
所以我不得不——我花了三个小时斡旋，最终达成协议，在洛克威举行葬礼。
When it came time to start dividing their parents things, Victor, a Rockaway, suggested Joe, officially a non Rockaway, that they do it using a lottery system. That's how their mother, who was also an attorney, by the way, divided her mother's estate among her many siblings.
当开始分割父母遗物时，身为洛克威派的维克多建议身为非洛克威派的乔使用抽签系统。顺便说一下，这正是他们的母亲（她也是一名律师）当年分配她母亲遗产给众多兄弟姐妹的方法。
The way the thing works is, basically everybody looks inside the book that Joe made up and writes down the items they want in the order that they want them and then sends their list to Joe. And then to figure out which sibling gets to pick first, and which picks second, and which picks third, and so on, Joe had to come up with a system.
运作方式基本上是，每个人翻看乔制作的那本书，按自己想要的顺序写下想要的物品，然后把清单发给乔。为了确定哪个兄弟姐妹先选，哪个第二，哪个第三，以此类推，乔不得不设计一套系统。
And so, my brother Victor called me, and we discussed it. And he said, how are you going to decide who gets to go first? I said, I have a nice cute little five-year-old boy who lives next door to me. I think I'm going to have him pick out of 12 ping-pong balls, like the New York State Lottery.
于是，我的兄弟维克多给我打电话，我们讨论了一下。他说，你打算怎么决定谁先选？我说，我邻居家里有个可爱的小男孩，五岁。我想让他从12个乒乓球里抽签，就像纽约州彩票那样。
Like one number and each ping pong ball for each of the 12 siblings.
就像12个兄弟姐妹每人一个数字对应一个乒乓球。
He said, oh, no, I wouldn't do that, if I were you. I said, what? Who can find something wrong with that? I'll videotape it, I said, it'll be all hilarious. He says, no, people might be suspicious that you rigged it.
他说，哦，不，如果我是你，我就不会那么做。我说，什么？谁会觉得那有问题？我说，我会录像，这会很有趣。他说，不，人们可能会怀疑你作弊。
It could have been the second video. The first video would have been no good, could have been thrown out. My brothers and sisters are quite bright. And they'll-- they'll easily detect the possible loophole in something.
可能会有第二段录像。第一段录像可能没用，会被扔掉。我的兄弟姐妹们非常聪明。他们会——他们很容易就能发现这里面可能存在的漏洞。
I said, what do you want me to do? Get Pricewaterhouse, like they do the Academy Awards? He said, that would be a great idea. So I literally got an accounting firm here in Orange County. And I called them, and I said, can you give me a list on your letterhead with the numbers 1 through 12 in random order.
我说，那你想让我怎么做？请普华永道会计师事务所吗，就像奥斯卡颁奖典礼那样？他说，那是个好主意。所以我真的联系了奥兰治县的一家会计师事务所。我给他们打电话说，能不能请你们用信纸给我一份清单，列出1到12的随机排序。
It was from the accounting firm that put their brother, Eddie, first. So he picks first, in the first round. And in the second round, it goes reverse order, and he picks last. Then third around, he's first again. Then the next round, last. Like a fantasy football snake draft, over and over, until all 196 items are gone.
正是那家会计师事务所把他们的兄弟埃迪排在第一位。所以第一轮他先选。第二轮反向顺序，他最后选。然后第三轮，他又第一。下一轮，最后。就像奇幻橄榄球的蛇形选秀一样，循环往复，直到196件物品全部分完。
If you get one of the most coveted items, their mom's silver, her engagement ring, you have to sit out a few rounds after that. Another popular item is a pen that John F Kennedy used to sign a bill, which they have because their dad, Edward Ray, was in the Kennedy administration at the State Department.
如果你拿到了最令人垂涎的物品之一，比如母亲的银器或订婚戒指，之后必须休息几轮。另一个热门物品是约翰·肯尼迪用来签署法案的一支笔，他们之所以有这件东西，是因为他们的父亲爱德华·雷曾在肯尼迪政府的国务院工作。
He was friends with the Kennedys. And later a Chief Judge at the US Court of International Trade. So the book has a certain amount of historical memorabilia, including a photo of the whole family with President Johnson, and 11-year-old Margo shaking his hand.
他是肯尼迪一家的朋友。后来成为美国国际贸易法院的首席法官。所以这本书里有一些历史纪念品，包括一张全家与约翰逊总统的合影，还有11岁的玛戈与他握手的照片。
There are only 196 items in the book, because lots of stuff was lost when Hurricane Sandy tore through their parents' house years ago. After the storm, Margo says, lots of items simply seemed to vanish, mysteriously. Don't get her started on who she thinks might have taken those items. Or, on the siblings who say that their mother and father gave them one of the items years ago, when they were alive.
书里只有196件物品，因为桑迪飓风几年前席卷了他们父母的房子，丢失了很多东西。风暴过后，玛戈说，很多东西似乎神秘地消失了。千万别让她提起她认为可能是谁拿走了那些东西。或者那些声称父母在世时就把东西送给他们的兄弟姐妹。
People would visit my mommy and leave with items. I'm like, oh, what happened to that painting that was here. Oh, mommy gave it to you. Mm, mommy's 90, she gave that to you? So then things would gradually disappear from the home. OK, I don't really want it. It's just like, what, are you kidding me?
人们来看望妈妈，走的时候就顺手带走东西。我就说，哦，原来放在这儿的那幅画呢？哦，妈妈送给你了。嗯，妈妈90岁了，她送给你了？东西就这么慢慢地从家里消失了。好吧，我其实并不想要它。只是觉得，什么，你在跟我开玩笑吗？
It just feels unfair.
这感觉真不公平。
The lottery was scheduled for Monday, April 15, last week. I was interviewing Margo just a couple days before it would happen. She'd already made her list of what she wanted, ranked in order.
抽签定在4月15日周一，也就是上周。我在抽签前两天采访了玛戈。她已经写好了她想要的清单，并按顺序排列。
OK, so read your list.
好的，请读一下你的清单。
This is not going to air till after April 15, right?
这节目在4月15号之后才会播出，对吧？
That's correct.
没错。
Correct.
对。
She was scared that a sibling would hear what she wanted and pick it for themselves just to spite her. One of the items she was nervous somebody else might get was this turkey platter she had her eye on. Her family used it every Thanksgiving when they were kids. There's a cartoonish painting of a turkey on it, colorful, kind of kitschy.
她担心兄弟姐妹会听到她想要什么，然后故意抢走来气她。她担心别人可能会拿走的一件东西是那个火鸡拼盘。他们小时候感恩节全家都会用它。上面画着一只卡通风格的火鸡，色彩鲜艳，有点庸俗艺术感。
There's a big, ugly ceramic turkey platter that we love. There's a little story to go with it, that may or may not be true, that it was bought at a garage sale from the Robert Kennedy's family, when they were moving. And that they sold it, and my mother bought it.
有一个我们很喜欢的大型丑陋陶瓷火鸡拼盘。关于它有一个小故事，真假难辨，说它是罗伯特·肯尼迪一家搬家时在车库拍卖会上买的。然后他们把它卖了，我妈妈买了下来。
Wait, so in this story, Bobby Kennedy, the attorney general of the United States, a millionaire, has got to move from one place to another. And he's thinking, what am I going to do-- I don't want to move all this stuff, I'm going to have a garage sale? And like people from the neighborhood are going to show up at Bobby Kennedy's house just to pick up random stuff from his family?
等等，在这个故事里，美国司法部长、百万富翁博比·肯尼迪要搬家，他在想，我该怎么办——我不想搬这些东西，我要搞个车库拍卖吗？就像邻居们会出现在博比·肯尼迪家门口，只是为了挑点零碎东西一样？
It is my story. And I think it's true, but I can't swear to it. But it's my story. And don't you dare let me find out it's not true.
这是我的故事。我觉得它是真的，但我不能发誓。但这是我的故事。你可别想让我发现它不是真的。
This totally improbable story is backed up by both Victor, a Rockaway, and Joe, a non Rockaway.
这个完全不可信的故事得到了维克多（洛克威派）和乔（非洛克威派）双方的背书。
I'm confident where it came from. It came from the estate of Robert F Kennedy after Kennedy was assassinated.
我很确信它的来源。它来自罗伯特·F·肯尼迪在遇刺后的遗产。
That turkey platter was Ethel Kennedy's. And that's how my parents got that turkey platter. My parents were good friends with the Kennedys.
那个火鸡拼盘是埃塞尔·肯尼迪的。这就是我父母得到它的方式。我父母和肯尼迪一家是好朋友。
You could call it a garage sale, but that's, to me-- I can't say it's wrong. But the garage of the Kennedy's is probably better than most. I think it was somebody in the Kennedy family was selling some items. And I assumed the money was going to go to a charity. OK? I'm sure that the Kennedy family did not need the proceeds of a platter.
你可以叫它车库拍卖，但在我看来——我不能说它不对。但肯尼迪家的车库可能比大多数人的都好。我想是肯尼迪家族里的某个人在卖一些物品。我想钱应该是捐给慈善机构的。好吗？我敢肯定肯尼迪一家不需要这一个拼盘的钱。
It took me a while talking to Margo to understand why this process of dividing their parents things has been so emotionally charged for everybody.
我和玛戈谈了很久，才明白为什么分割父母遗物的过程会让每个人都情绪如此激动。
A lot of this is just whose mommy's favorite and daddy's favorite, despite the fact that you're in your 60s. My parents always had favorites. So everyone was always a little bit jealous of everyone else.
这很多时候就是在争论谁是妈妈最喜欢的，谁是爸爸最喜欢的，尽管你已经60多岁了。我的父母总是有偏爱的。所以每个人总是嫉妒其他人。
Joe agreed with that.
乔也同意这一点。
We'd talk about this all the time, who's number one. There's no doubt who number one was. My sister Mary Anne was number one. And a lot of this just dealt with trying to get my parents attention, affection, and love. Because my parents had so little time to give to each one of us. Everybody was fighting for my parents' attention.
我们经常谈论这个，谁是老大。毫无疑问谁是老大。我姐姐玛丽·安是老大的地位。这很大程度上与试图争取父母的关注、关爱和爱有关。因为父母能分给我们的时间太少了。每个人都在争夺父母的注意。
I don't feel I knew my father very well, until I went to law school. Then, all of a sudden, he took great interest in me. But where was he the first 22 years of my life? All of a sudden, I became important. Before that, I was just one of the runts in the family.
我觉得在我上法学院之前并不怎么了解父亲。然后，突然间，他对我产生了浓厚的兴趣。但我生命的前22年他在哪呢？突然间，我变得重要了。在那之前，我只是家里的一只小蚂蚁。
One of the things Joe did, back when he was little, to be more than just one of the runts, was he memorized all kinds of information about American presidents to impress his dad and his dad's fancy friends.
乔小时候为了不只做一只小蚂蚁所做的事情之一，就是背诵各种关于美国总统的信息，来给父亲和父亲那些时髦的朋友留下深刻印象。
Yeah, my father would bring me out to dinner parties. And I'd get all this attention from reciting the presidents, and when they were born, and when they died, and who was Secretary of State, who their vice president was.
是的，父亲会带我出席晚宴。我通过背诵总统名单、他们的出生日期、死亡日期、国务卿是谁、副总统是谁，赢得了所有人的关注。
So my other siblings started memorizing it. It was all driven by the same thing. And that is, oh, look how he got attention, look how he got affection, why can't I do the same thing? And so, to this day, I can rattle off the presidents' names. I learned that as a five, six-year-old from--
于是我的其他兄弟姐妹也开始背诵。这一切都是由同样的事情驱动的。那就是，哦，看他怎么得到关注，看他怎么得到关爱，为什么我不能做同样的事？所以直到今天，我还能脱口而出总统的名字。这是我在五六岁时从——
OK, wait-- bring it, let's hear the presidents.
好吧，等等——来吧，让我们听听总统名单。
Oh, you mean, Washington, Adams, Jefferson, Madison, Monroe, Quincy Adams, Jackson, Van Buren, Harrison, Tyler, Polk, Taylor, Fillmore, Pierce, Buchanan, Lincoln, Johnson, Grant, Hayes, Garfield, Arthur, Cleveland, like that?
哦，你是说，华盛顿、亚当斯、杰斐逊、麦迪逊、门罗、昆西·亚当斯、杰克逊、范布伦、哈里森、泰勒、波尔克、泰勒、菲尔莫尔、皮尔斯、布坎南、林肯、约翰逊、格兰特、海斯、加菲尔德、亚瑟、克利夫兰，诸如此类？
Yeah, like that.
是的，就像那样。
And we used to time it on who could do it the fastest. But my father was very competitive. So he has to take some responsibility. He was always number one in his class. He spoke five languages. He played seven instruments.
我们过去常计时比谁背得最快。但我父亲非常好胜。所以他得承担一些责任。他总是班里的第一名。他会说五种语言。他会演奏七种乐器。
He was a student a Buddy Rich's. He was just a Renaissance man. He was Assistant Secretary of State. So to measure up to an imposing parent like that, you're always going to feel inadequate. That's what my brothers and sisters have to take with them.
他是巴迪·里奇的学生。他简直就是个全才。他曾任副国务卿。所以要衡量这样一个令人敬畏的父母，你总是会感到不足。这就是我的兄弟姐妹们必须背负的东西。
Wow, what a harsh legacy to give your kids. In a way, it's like something nobody would wish on their children, that kind of legacy.
哇，给孩子们留下的遗产太沉重了。在某种程度上，这就像一种没人会希望给孩子的东西，那种遗产。
Yeah, life's a bitch, isn't it? It's a-- that's the way it goes when you have great parents. People-- you often see families fall apart when the parents were great people.
是的，生活真是一团糟，不是吗？这——当你拥有伟大的父母时，情况往往就是这样。人们——你经常会看到当父母是伟人时，家庭反而分崩离析。
When the parents are gone, there's all kinds of unforeseen stuff they leave us with, stuff they never intended. The objects, and the money, and the property they leave behind, in a way it's so straightforward, compared to that other stuff. There comes a day, it's divided, and then it's over, which by the way, did happen for this family.
当父母去世后，他们留给我们各种意想不到的东西，他们从未打算留下的东西。他们留下的物品、钱和财产，在某种程度上其实很简单，比起那些其他东西。总有一天，它们会被分配，然后就结束了，顺便提一下，这个家庭确实已经这样完成了。
They had the lottery, a day early, on April 14, last Sunday. Margo did get the turkey platter she wanted. Victor got the judge's robe that his dad used to wear, that he wanted. Joe got JFK's pen. By all reports, everybody was pretty happy with what they got. And very soon, after the property is actually handed out to each sibling, in a way, it's like the official end of them as a family.
他们在上周日4月14日提前一天进行了抽签。玛戈确实得到了她想要的火鸡拼盘。维克多得到了他父亲生前穿过的法官袍。乔得到了JFK的笔。根据所有报告，每个人对他们得到的东西都相当满意。而且很快，在财产真正分配给每个兄弟姐妹之后，在某种意义上，这就像他们作为一个家庭的正式终结。
Margo, anyway, says that she sees no reason why she would ever have contact with like five of them, ever again. The others, though, I have to say, she's super close with, maybe closer after all this. Ready for the next phase, whatever that is.
不管怎么说，玛戈说她看不到任何理由会再次与其中五个兄弟姐妹有任何联系。不过，必须得说，她和其他人关系超级亲密，也许在经历了这一切之后更加亲密了。准备好迎接下一个阶段，不管那是什么。
I think it'll be really good, we just-- go on with your life. Enjoy your life and get over it, including myself, I say that too, OK.
我觉得这会很好，我们只是——继续你的生活。享受你的生活，放下这一切，包括我自己，我也这么说，好吗。
Well, today on our program, people leave us, and we'll have to scramble and figure out what to do next. We have stories of an entire town up and leaving, except for four guys. And another town, where kids got home one day from school to find that their parents were gone. And what do they do now? From WBEZ Chicago, this is American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好吧，今天在我们的节目中，人们离开我们，我们不得不手忙脚乱地想下一步该怎么办。我们有关于一个城镇全体离开，只剩下四个人的故事。还有另一个城镇，孩子们某天放学回家发现父母不见了。他们现在该怎么办？来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请留在我们节目中。
Act One, The Sudden Departure. When we started putting this show together, we talked a lot about the rapture. You know, when the righteous get lifted to heaven, just a small number of them, leaving the rest of us behind. And I say us, because I know exactly where I end up in that story. Maybe you've seen the TV show about this kind of thing, The Leftovers.
第一幕，突然的离开。当我们开始策划这个节目时，谈了很多关于被提拔的事。你知道，当义人被提升到天堂，只有少数人，剩下的人被抛在后面。我说“我们”，因为我知道我在那个故事里最终会是什么结局。也许你见过关于这种事情的电视节目，《守望尘世》。
Anyway, one of our producers, Lilly Sullivan, she visited a town, where all in one morning, hundreds of people learned that their loved ones are gone and they were left behind. Anna heard when she was at school. She was a junior, eating lunch by the football field.
总之，我们的制片人之一，莉莉·沙利文，她参观了一个城镇，那里的人们在一天早晨，几百个人得知他们心爱的人离开了，而他们被留在了后面。安娜在学校时听说了。她当时是个大二学生，正在足球场边吃午饭。
And one of my teachers, she came up towards me, and said someone needed me at the office. So, I just got off the bleachers and walked to the office. I didn't think too much of it.
我的一位老师走过来跟我说，办公室有人找。所以，我走下看台去了办公室。我没多想。
When she got there, her mom and her aunt were waiting for her.
当她到达那里时，她的母亲和阿姨正在等她。
And my mom just came up to me and hugged me. And she looked at me, and she's like, it's OK, we'll get him out. I still didn't understand.
妈妈走过来抱住我。她看着我说，没事的，我们会把他救出来的。我还是没听懂。
Not far away, when school ended, 13-year-old Adrian had a feeling that something was going on, because his dad was not acting normal at all when he picked up him and his little sisters, Gabriella and Eva.
不远处，放学时，13岁的阿德里安有一种感觉，因为父亲在接他和他的小妹妹加布里埃拉和伊娃时表现得很不正常。
Like, I was sitting in front of the car. He was kind of upset, or something like he usually says to us, like, oh, how was your day.
就像，我坐在车前。他有点难过，或者像他通常对我们说的那样，比如，哦，你今天过得怎么样。
This is Gabriella.
这是加布里埃拉。
I remember asking, can I use the computer when I get home. He said no. And then I asked him, can we go outside. And he said no. Like, I saw in the mirror, like if he was in a different world, not here.
我记得问，我回家能用电脑吗。他说不行。然后我问他，我们能出去吗。他说不行。就像，我在镜子里看到，他好像在另一个世界，不在这里。
Their little sister, Eva, was 10.
他们的小妹妹伊娃当时10岁。
And me and my sister were like, what's going on dad? And he-- then, he was like, I'm going to tell you when we get home. So, then we got home. He said to sit down on the couch. And he started to tell us that they got my mom. He was like, the immigration got your mom. Then all of us, like, just started to cry.
我和我姐姐问，爸爸怎么了？然后——他就像是说，到家我就告诉你们。于是，我们到家了。他说坐在沙发上。他开始告诉我们他们抓走了妈妈。他说，移民局抓走了妈妈。然后我们所有人，就像，开始哭。
Did you know what that meant?
你知道那意味着什么吗？
Sort of.
大概吧。
What happened was that immigration had done a workplace raid, the kind where ICE swoops into a factory or business and arrests hundreds or dozens of undocumented workers-- big, workplace raids, where hundreds get arrested all at once.
发生的事情是移民局进行了一次工作场所突袭，就像ICE突袭一家工厂或企业，逮捕成百上千名无证工人的那种——大型工作场所突袭，成百上千人一次性被捕。
The US hadn't done them for a decade. But then the Trump administration brought them back. ICE says that when they do these operations, the employer is the primary target, the boss. When they find undocumented workers at a work site, they don't turn a blind eye. And since they know ahead of time that workers will probably be there, they often bring buses.
美国已经十年没这么做了。但后来特朗普政府恢复了这种行动。ICE称，当他们进行这些行动时，雇主是主要目标，老板。当他们在工作地点发现无证工人时，他们不会睁一只眼闭一只眼。由于他们提前知道工人很可能在那里，他们经常带上大巴。
So anyway, my co-worker Lilly Sullivan, she was interested in these big raids, because she'd heard that when one of them happens, it ripples through the whole community. It doesn't just affect the families that lose somebody, but everybody else in town as well.
所以，我的同事莉莉·沙利文，她对这些大规模突袭很感兴趣，因为她听说当这种事情发生时，它会波及整个社区。它不仅影响失去家人的家庭，也影响城里的其他人。
And the place she visited was the very first place that the Trump administration hit with one of these raids, Morristown, Tennessee. That raid happened a year ago this month. She put together this story about, first, the families impacted by the raid, and then everybody else in town.
她参观的地方正是特朗普政府首次发动突袭的地方，田纳西州的莫里斯敦。那次突袭发生在去年本月。她整理了这个故事，关于首先是受到突袭影响的家庭，然后是城里的其他人。
We've changed all the kids' names in this story, here on the radio. Here's Lilly.
我们在广播里更改了所有孩子在这个故事里的名字。这是莉莉。
ICE picked up 97 undocumented workers that day, almost everyone working at a slaughterhouse outside of town. People told me it was like a bomb had gone off. Helicopters were circling the town. A big public road was blocked off. Officers in uniforms they didn't recognize directing traffic.
ICE那天抓走了97名无证工人，几乎是镇外一家屠宰场的所有工人。人们告诉我，就像炸弹爆炸了一样。直升机在城镇上空盘旋。一条大的公共道路被封锁。穿着他们不认识的制服的官员在指挥交通。
Factory parking lots all over town that were usually full emptied out, as workers scared of ICE fled home for the day. One family I talked to a lot about the days that followed, I'll call them the Garcias. Their dad had been picked up the morning of the raid, while the kids were at school, doing school stuff.
全城通常挤满人的工厂停车场空了，工人们害怕ICE，逃回家里躲避。有一个家庭我谈了很多关于随后的日子，我叫他们加西亚一家。他们的父亲在突袭那天早上被抓走，当时孩子们在学校，忙着学校的事。
Manny was in the sixth grade and rode the bus home with his friends. They were talking about math homework and gossiping. That's his word. He was surprised to see his mom's car in the driveway when the bus pulled up. He usually gets home before her.
曼尼在六年级，和朋友们坐校车回家。他们正在谈论数学作业和八卦。那是他的话。当校车停下时，他很惊讶看到母亲的车在车道上。他通常比她先到家。
So, I was like, OK, mom, mom. Mom was home. But the door was locked. I was like, ma, ma-ma. And I didn't hear anything. So I'd start knocking, and I say my little brother's name, and open up.
所以，我喊着，妈，妈。妈妈在家。但门锁着。我说，妈，妈。我什么都没听到。所以我就开始敲门，喊我弟弟的名字，快开门。
Were you surprised it was locked?
你对门锁着感到惊讶吗？
Yeah. He never locks it, unless he's like scared or he's doing something.
是的。他从不锁门，除非他害怕或者他在做什么事。
Manny figured his little brother, Eric, was making videos and had locked the door so nobody would walk in on him.
曼尼以为他弟弟埃里克在录视频，锁门是为了不让人进去。
Cause like, he records videos of himself, like making some slime.
因为就像，他录自己做史莱姆的视频。
Videos of making slime?
做史莱姆的视频？
Yeah. This really, ooey, gooey liquid that he could play with, he did that all the time.
是的。那种黏糊糊的液体，他可以玩，他一直做这个。
Eric finally let him in.
埃里克终于让他进去了。
And he just immediately told me, hey, our dad is gone. They took our dad. I felt my stomach, it was-- felt like I was going to vomit.
他立刻告诉我，嘿，爸爸不见了。他们带走了爸爸。我感觉到我的胃，就像——感觉像是要吐了。
Eric, who's nine, had gotten home right before Manny. Their mom was home and she told them right away.
9岁的埃里克比曼尼先回家。他们的妈妈在家，她立刻告诉了他们。
And then my mom said that they got your dad, migration. And I was just like-- I said, what's that? What does that mean?
然后妈妈说移民局抓走了爸爸。我就——我说，那是什么？那意味着什么？
Their mom had locked herself in the house. She'd been sitting inside, curtains drawn, lights off, hiding quietly since morning. They sat with her on the couch, making no noise. She'd been watching Facebook Live updates all day, people posting about their families.
他们的妈妈把自己锁在屋里。她坐在里面，拉着窗帘，关着灯，从早上起就安静地躲着。他们陪她坐在沙发上，一点声音也不敢出。她整天都在看Facebook的直播更新，人们发布关于他们家人的消息。
She knew that a lot of people had gone to where the arrested people were being held, in a big armory outside of town. All day, their mom had been too afraid to head down there, afraid to get so close to ICE. She's undocumented too.
她知道很多人已经去了被捕者被关押的地方，在城外的一个大军械库里。一整天，他们的妈妈都太害怕不敢去那里，害怕离ICE太近。她也是无证件的。
If she were taken, her kids would be completely on their own. But after seeing so many people there all day, including some people that she knew didn't have papers, she decided to risk it. Her husband's diabetic and he needed his medication.
如果她被抓走，孩子们就真的无依无靠了。但在整天看到很多人去那里之后，包括一些她知道没有身份的人，她决定冒险。她丈夫有糖尿病，需要药物。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And so I pulled myself together, she said, and I took the risk.
所以她打起精神，她说，我冒了这个险。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I said, let's go, they can't get all of us who are down there.
我说，走吧，他们不可能抓走所有去那儿的人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
If they take us, they take us.
如果他们抓走我们，就抓走吧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I got up and I went. She brought one of her older sons with her, her 13 year old. He's a citizen. And she left her younger two kids at home. She told Manny to take care of his little brother until they got back. As she left, she did the thing that lots of moms do to distract their kids in an emergency.
我起床走了。她带了一个大儿子，13岁。他是公民。她把小一点的两个孩子留在家里。她告诉曼尼照顾弟弟直到他们回来。离开时，她做了很多妈妈为了在紧急情况下分散孩子注意力会做的事。
My mom told me start cleaning, and then we started cleaning.
妈妈让我开始打扫卫生，然后我们就开始打扫了。
So, first we do living room, like sweep, clean what's on floor. Then we do the dishes, put them back where they are. And then, dining room, clean the table, clean the chairs. But it was usually quiet. We never liked talked on that day. We didn't talk the whole time we were cleaning.
所以，我们先打扫客厅，比如扫地，清理地板上的东西。然后我们洗碗，放回原处。然后，餐厅，擦桌子，擦椅子。但通常很安静。我们那天甚至没说话。我们在打扫的时候一直没说话。
And after we were done cleaning, which was nighttime, I got something to eat.
打扫完后，已经是晚上了，我吃了点东西。
Manny made Eric dinner, a pop tart and milk and put on cartoons for him, Teen Titans Go. He sat next to him while he watched. Manny, himself, was glued to his phone, watching all the Facebook updates and Snapchatting with friends, trying to find news.
曼尼给埃里克做了晚饭，一个披萨饼和牛奶，给他放了动画片，《少年泰坦》。他在旁边陪着他看。曼尼自己盯着手机，看着所有的Facebook更新，和朋友Snapchat，试图寻找消息。
Around 11:00, they got a call from their mom. She told them to go to bed. They had school tomorrow. She said they'd be home soon. But neither of the boys could sleep.
11点左右，他们接到妈妈的电话。她让他们去睡觉。明天还要上学。她说他们很快就回家了。但两个男孩都睡不着。
I was feeling sad that-- that-- oh, he's not actually coming back. But then, every time my mom always said, he's coming back, he's coming back.
我感到很难过，那——那——哦，他实际上回不来了。但妈妈总是说，他会回来的，他会回来的。
Did you not believe that he would come back that night? Or were you worried that he wouldn't?
你是不相信他那天晚上会回来吗？还是你担心他回不来？
I didn't believe he was coming.
我不相信他会回来。
Why not?
为什么？
I don't know.
不知道。
Yeah, were you scared?
是啊，你害怕吗？
I was pretty scared, cause-- I was scared it was going to be me and him all by ourselves. And they would be gone. And we'd be just me and him. Just I was thinking all of that in my mind. Cause I have to take care of him. I have to cook him food and I have to like, you know, take responsibility and take care of him.
我挺害怕的，因为——我害怕我和他就这么孤零零的。如果他们都不见了。就剩下我和他。我脑子里全是这些念头。因为我得照顾他。我得给他做饭，我得就像，你知道，承担责任照顾他。
Wait, but how old are you? Isn't that too much to do?
等等，但你多大了？做这些事是不是太过了？
I mean, I'm 12, so, I'm pretty-- I already know everything about him, and what he likes, and everything. So, I think I'll be pretty good in taking care of him.
我是说，我12岁，所以，我挺——我已经了解他的一切，他喜欢什么，所有事。所以，我觉得我照顾他应该会挺好的。
Eventually, their mom came home. Their dad didn't. At 11:00 that night, he was one of 54 people that ICE sent to detention in Alabama. A teacher who'd gone to the armory that day to be with his students and try to help, he told me that seeing these white buses line up and file out in the dark, no goodbyes, no information, it felt like something out of the X Files.
最终，妈妈回家了。爸爸没有。那天晚上11点，他是ICE送到阿拉巴马州拘留的54人之一。一位当天去军械库和学生在一起并试图帮忙的老师告诉我，看到这些白色的巴士在黑暗中排队驶出，没有告别，没有信息，感觉就像《X档案》里的情节。
Of the 97 undocumented workers picked up that morning, ICE let 32 people go, one by one, over the course of the day. ICE had put them into deportation proceedings, but said they could wait for their court dates at home. It was strange, who got released and who didn't. They released mostly women, some single mothers, but not all of them.
那天早上被抓走的97名无证工人中，ICE在一天之内陆续放了32人。ICE启动了他们的驱逐程序，但表示他们可以在家等待开庭日期。奇怪的是，谁被释放了，谁没有。他们主要释放了妇女，一些单身母亲，但不是所有人。
They released some people with chronic illnesses, but not all of them. There were a few couples who worked together at the plant, couples with kids, both parents detained. In cases like that, someone told me that ICE told them to choose-- said, we'll let one of you go home, choose who. People always chose the mom.
他们释放了一些患有慢性病的人，但不是所有人。有几对夫妻一起在工厂工作，有孩子的夫妻，父母双方都被拘留了。在这种情况下，有人告诉我，ICE让他们选择——说，我们会放你们其中一个回家，选一个吧。人们总是选择妈妈。
I talked to the special agent in charge of the Morristown operation. He told me ICE has a policy to not leave kids with no parent or caretaker. So when two parents are detained, they might release one. It's at the officer's discretion.
我采访了莫里斯敦行动的负责人特工。他告诉我ICE有一项政策，不让孩子失去父母或监护人。所以当父母双方被拘留时，他们可能会释放一个。这取决于官员的裁量权。
Morristown is small enough, under 30,000 people, that nobody in town could avoid what happened. Everyone saw the helicopters. Lots of people knew someone who'd been picked up or knew their kids or other relatives. When dozens of officers come storming into a small town, rounding up a hundred people, it's the kind of thing where people spill out of their houses and watch.
莫里斯敦很小，不到3万人，没人能避开发生的事情。每个人都看到了直升机。很多人认识被抓走的人，或者认识他们的孩子或其他亲戚。当几十名官员冲进一个小镇，围捕一百人时，这是人们会从屋里出来围观的那种事情。
Krista Etter lives up the hill from the plant. She had been scared that there was some criminal on the loose. She called her daughter, who was at home, and told her to lock the doors. When Krista heard it was a raid at the slaughterhouse, she hiked across the field by her house to go see.
克里斯塔·埃特住在那家工厂上面的山上。她一直担心有罪犯在逃。她给在家的女儿打电话，让她锁好门。当克里斯塔听说屠宰场发生了突袭时，她穿过家旁边的田野去看看。
She saw the ICE trailer, officers cordoning off the entrance to the plant. Krista's a Trump supporter. She's not a fan of illegal immigration. Most of the area is that way. The county went 77% to Trump. She didn't know anyone who'd been directly affected.
她看到了ICE的拖车，官员封锁了工厂入口。克里斯塔是特朗普的支持者。她不喜欢非法移民。该地区大多数人都这样。这个县77%的人支持特朗普。她不认识直接受到影响的人。
Over the weekend, she went to a vigil for the parents who'd been taken away, not because she wanted to. She didn't. She's the general manager for a local paper. And they asked her to take pictures. She says that when she showed up, she was actually a little angry that all these people were there at all, like what do they expect? These people broke the law. They should have seen it coming.
周末，她参加了一场为被带走的父母举行的守夜活动，不是因为她想去。她不想。她是当地一家报纸的总经理。他们让她去拍照。她说当她出现时，她其实有点生气，因为这些人为什么要来这里，他们期待什么？这些人违法了。他们早该料到有这一天。
I thought this possibly was a good thing, that ICE was cracking down on immigration. They're here illegally. They need to go home.
我认为这可能是一件好事，ICE正在打击非法移民。他们非法留在这里。他们需要回家。
And then she started listening to the kids at the mic.
然后她开始听孩子们在麦克风前的发言。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
There was a young man. He was a teenager, 14, 15 years old, that said, he just wanted his mom to come home.
有个年轻人。他是个十几岁的孩子，14、15岁，说他只想妈妈回家。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He didn't have anybody else. He just wanted his mom to come home.
他没有别人。他只想妈妈回家。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It just really, just shook my soul. It was-- it was almost overwhelming, because there were so many children speaking. And-- and, I actually kind of had to get out of there. Because I was like, it's getting hot. And I have health issues. And I was like, I need to-- I have to remove myself, you know, walk out to my car, get a breath.
这真的，震撼了我的灵魂。太——太让人难以承受了，因为有那么多孩子在说话。而且——而且，我真的不得不离开那里。因为我当时想，天太热了。我有健康问题。我当时想，我需要——我必须离开，你知道，走到车里，喘口气。
And God's kind of going, see, I wanted you here, because you're not correct in your thinking. You're not correct in thinking that this is so black and white. Because when I heard crack down on illegal immigration, I interpreted it as a crackdown on illegal immigrants that were criminals. If there was a drug situation, you know, violent criminals, pedophile, any kind of situation of that nature. That's what I expected.
上帝就像在说，看，我想要你在这里，因为你的想法是不正确的。你认为这是非黑即白的想法是不正确的。因为当我听到打击非法移民时，我把它解读为打击那些罪犯非法移民。如果有什么毒品情况，你知道，暴力罪犯、恋童癖，任何这种性质的情况。那才是我所期待的。
And I really believe I'm not the only one who did that. I don't think anybody ever really stopped to think that they were going to go after the family man working at the meatpacking plant. That's not what I had in mind.
我真心相信我不是唯一一个这么想的人。我不认为有人真正停下来想过他们会去抓那个在肉类加工厂工作的顾家男人。那不是我脑子里的想法。
I'm still a President Trump supporter. I guess, I have to hold out hope that maybe he didn't understand he was going after the guy in the meatpacking plant. I mean, I guess he probably does.
我仍然是特朗普总统的支持者。我想，我必须抱有希望，也许他并不知道他要去抓那个肉类加工厂的人。我是说，我想他可能知道。
I talked to a lot of people in town, who, after the raid, said they felt stunned. People kept reminding me, this is the Bible Belt. This town's God fearing. There's over 100 churches in the area. Love thy neighbor, people take that seriously.
我和镇上的很多人谈过，突袭后，他们说感到震惊。人们一直提醒我，这是圣经带。这个城镇敬畏上帝。该地区有100多座教堂。爱邻如己，人们非常认真地对待这一点。
And that really shaped the town's response to the raid. Reverend David Williams is a pastor in town at a Southern Baptist Church. He describes himself as Republican, conservative, very pro-life, pro military, pro Second Amendment. Also, he led a prayer at the vigil.
这真正塑造了城镇对突袭的反应。大卫·威廉姆斯牧师是镇上一家南方浸信会教堂的牧师。他形容自己是共和党人，保守派，非常反堕胎，支持军队，支持宪法第二修正案。他还曾在守夜活动上领祷。
That Jesus loves the little children.
耶稣爱这小孩子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Regardless of their color.
不管他们的肤色如何。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Or the status of their citizenship.
或者他们的公民身份状况。
[APPLAUSE]
[鼓掌]
He felt he needed to do it, after driving past the raid all day, on his way between his house and his church.
他觉得必须这样做，因为整天开车经过突袭现场，在往返家和教堂的路上。
And it was very creepy to see a particular ethnic group basically rounded up. As Americans, we are better than this.
看到一个特定的族群基本被围捕，真的很恐怖。作为美国人，我们理应更好。
I'm just trying to understand, this is kind of exactly what President Trump said he would do. He promised workplace raids, right? And then, everyone was really shocked when it actually happened. Why are people surprised, do you know?
我只是想了解，这基本上正是特朗普总统所说的他会做的事情。他承诺进行工作场所突袭，对吧？然后，每个人在它真正发生时真的感到震惊。为什么人们感到惊讶，你知道吗？
I don't know. I don't-- I hope-- I don't think when people voted for Trump that they were voting for more raids. I think people were voting for a secure border. You know, surely people didn't vote that families would be separated, and that families torn apart, and children scared, when am I going to see my mother or father again?
我不知道。我不——我希望——我不认为人们投票给特朗普时是在投票支持更多的突袭。我认为人们投票支持边境安全。你知道，人们肯定不是投票支持家庭被拆散，家庭四分五裂，孩子害怕，我什么时候才能再见到我的母亲或父亲？
We're talking about our neighbors. They're in the shadow of the steeple of the church where I serve. So I have a moral and biblical obligation. It became-- it became a divine thing, yeah. I hope I have a job after this interview.
我们谈论的是我们的邻居。他们就在我服务的教堂尖顶之下。所以我有一种道德和圣经的义务。这成了——这成了某种神圣的事情，是的。我希望采访后我还能保住工作。
Other people told me the same thing, their faith told them that they needed to help these families. So this very conservative town stepped up to help the people who'd been detained and their families.
其他人告诉我也一样，他们的信仰告诉他们需要帮助这些家庭。所以这个非常保守的城镇挺身而出帮助那些被拘留的人和他们的家庭。
Morristown's pretty small, but it's also pretty well integrated. Latinos have been there for decades. Whites and Latinos live in the same neighborhoods. The schools are mixed. By the morning after the raid, the town had raised $30,000 to bond people out of detention and to help with necessities. Two weeks later, it was up to $90,000. Again, here's Krista.
莫里斯敦很小，但也相当融合。拉美裔在那里已经几十年了。白人和拉美裔住在同一个社区。学校是混合的。突袭后的第二天早上，该镇筹集了3万美元用于保释人们出拘留所，并帮助支付生活必需品。两周后，金额增加到了9万美元。再说一次，这是克里斯塔。
I think some of it was guilt. It was guilt. Because you don't raise the kind of money in these communities, because we all thought we were right in our assumptions. Do you see what I mean? It was guilt. We were like, wow, we all thought that they should all go home. We all thought we needed to build a wall.
我想其中一部分是内疚。是内疚。因为你在这些社区筹集不到这种钱，因为我们都以为我们的假设是正确的。你知道我的意思吗？是内疚。我们就像，哇，我们都认为他们都应该回家。我们都认为我们需要建一堵墙。
And then, all of a sudden, we watched families being torn apart. We never thought about those that were left behind.
然后，突然间，我们看着家庭四分五裂。我们从未考虑过那些被留下的人。
Now they did. Pastors in town started a telephone chain, opening up churches around town as sanctuaries, with cots for people who were scared that ICE would come back. When an immigration raid hits, you don't usually hear about this kind of response-- a town wide effort to pick up the pieces.
现在他们考虑到了。镇上的牧师们发起了一个电话链，将镇上的教堂作为避难所开放，为那些害怕ICE回来的人提供行军床。当移民突袭发生时，你通常听不到这种反应——一个城镇范围内的努力来收拾残局。
Longtime residents lined up to volunteer at churches, brought trucks full of food and donations. One organizer told me that a local bishop dropped off $5,000 and said, this is from my church, I'm sorry, this is not what we intended. People connected families with lawyers, wrote hundreds of character references for people detained.
长期居民排队到教堂做志愿者，带来了满载食品和捐款的卡车。一位组织者告诉我，当地一位主教留下了5000美元并说，这是来自我的教堂，对不起，这不是我们的本意。人们帮家庭联系律师，为被拘留者写了数百封品行证明书。
The Garcia family, where the kids cleaned the house the day of the raid, the kids' teachers came by each week with bags of groceries. And two months later, at the crack of dawn, their dad came home. The town donated $1,000 to go toward his bond. And the mom was able to scrape together another $9,000 and bond him out.
加西亚一家，就是孩子们在突袭那天打扫房子的家庭，孩子们的老师每周都带着杂货袋过来。两个月后，在破晓时分，他们的爸爸回家了。镇上捐了1000美元用于支付他的保释金。妈妈设法又凑了9000美元，把他保释出来。
His older sons picked him up from Louisiana. They drove all night to get home. He hadn't told his younger sons he was out. Their mom got them out of bed, saying, wake up, we're going to McDonald's for breakfast. Hurry up, we're about to leave.
他大一点的儿子把他从路易斯安那州接回来。他们开了一整晚的车才到家。他没告诉小儿子他出来了。妈妈把他们从床上叫醒，说，起床，我们要去麦当劳吃早餐。快点，我们马上要走了。
They were putting on their shoes when their dad opened the screen door and said, so what are you going to get me from McDonald's? Their mom actually videoed it on her phone.
他们正穿鞋时，爸爸打开纱门说，你们要从麦当劳给我带什么？妈妈真的用手机拍了下来。
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
The second his dad walks in, the youngest son, Eric, loses it. Starts wailing.
爸爸进来的那一刻，最小的儿子埃里克失控了。开始大哭。
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
He's hugging his dad and saying, papi.
他抱着爸爸喊着，爸爸。
The raid happened a year ago this month. And even now, the kids still cling to their dad.
突袭发生在去年本月。即使现在，孩子们仍然粘着爸爸。
You always want to go with him wherever he goes?
无论他去哪你总是想跟着他吗？
Yeah, even just like go pick up tortillas for whenever mom's cooking. Or if he's just going to run errand or go pay a bill, or something like that. He's like, oh, only one person can go, because we can't all go. So we all take turns going with him sometimes. Because it only gets fair.
是的，甚至就像只是去买妈妈做饭用的玉米饼。或者如果他只是去跑个腿或去交账单之类的。他会说，哦，只能去一个人，因为我们不能全去。所以有时候我们轮流跟他去。因为这样才公平。
Are you serious? You take turns going with him when he goes out?
你是认真的吗？你们轮流跟着他出门？
Yeah.
是的。
Their dad has his reasons for only taking one kid at a time.
他们的父亲有他不带所有孩子一起去的理由。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Well, no, because they asked for a ton of stuff. And then one of them doesn't have his shoes on, and one isn't dressed. So I just take the one who's ready.
嗯，不，因为他们要一堆东西。然后其中一个没穿鞋，另一个没穿衣服。所以我只带那个准备好的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The first one, and then later, if I go back out, I take the other one, like that.
第一个，然后后来，如果我再出去，我就带另一个，就是这样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's like wherever I go, they want to go too. And sometimes, their mom doesn't want me to go out alone either.
就像无论我走到哪，他们也想去。有时候，他们的妈妈也不想让我单独出门。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
They think that at any moment, the same thing will happen.
他们认为随时随地同样的事情会发生。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I hope not.
我希望不要。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But only God knows what will happen.
但只有上帝知道会发生什么。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So, yeah.
所以，是啊。
He's still at home. He's in deportation proceedings. His court date is next year. And no one knows if he'll have to leave. So they have to plan.
他还在家。他正在被驱逐出境程序中。他的开庭日期是明年。没人知道他是否必须离开。所以他们必须做计划。
The older kids are getting jobs. The younger ones are learning to cook, so that they can help their mom, preparing for that possibility in case he goes.
大一点的孩子正在找工作。小一点的正在学习做饭，这样他们可以帮助妈妈，为万一他离开的可能性做准备。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, flames moving in from all sides. An entire town flees. Only four people left behind. What's their next move? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，火焰从四面八方逼近。整个城镇逃离。只有四个人被留在后面。他们的下一步是什么？一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台回来，当我们的节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme. Today's program, Left Behind, the stories where people are suddenly gone and everyone leftover has to figure out how to handle whatever comes next.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题。今天的节目，《被留下的人》，讲述人们突然消失，所有留下的人必须弄清楚如何处理接下来发生的事情。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Passed Over.
我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，被忽略。
So last fall, the deadliest wildfire in 100 years happened in Northern California. Climate change is real. 150,000 acres burned. 85 people died. 40,000 were displaced from their homes. Two entire communities, Paradise and Concow, were gone in the first 6 and 1/2 hours. Other towns are partially destroyed.
去年秋天，加利福尼亚北部发生了100年来最致命的野火。气候变化是真实的。烧毁了15万英亩土地。85人死亡。4万人流离失所。两个完整的社区，天堂镇和康考镇，在最初的6个半小时内消失了。其他城镇部分被毁。
Aerial photos show street after street with rectangles of ash in rows. All along the sides of the streets, former homes and buildings. Every disaster has lucky survivors. In this fire, one place that made it through is called Helltown. That's Helltown, like H-E- double L. It was left behind when so much else was destroyed.
航拍照片显示街道两旁成排的矩形灰烬。街道两旁，曾经的房屋和建筑。每场灾难都有幸运的幸存者。在这场大火中，一个幸存的地方叫地狱镇（Helltown）。就是地狱镇，H-E-double L那个。当其他很多地方被毁时，它被留了下来。
We heard about Helltown from reporter Robert Baird's great piece in GQ, it is in next month's print edition. It's online right now. Nancy Updike has our story.
我们从记者罗伯特·贝尔德在《智族GQ》上的精彩文章中听说了地狱镇，它在下个月的印刷版中。现在可以在网上看到。南希·厄普代克带来了我们的故事。
Helltown is tiny, fewer than 20 houses in a canyon. No store, no post office, more of an enclave than a town. What happened there only makes sense if you know that, A, a trained firefighter was involved, and B, the group of friends who went back to Helltown after it had been evacuated and decided to try and save it, all grew up together, are super tight, and either still live in and around Helltown, or have family there.
地狱镇很小，峡谷里不到20栋房子。没有商店，没有邮局，与其说是城镇，不如说是一个飞地。那里发生的事情只有在你了解以下情况时才说得通：A，有一名训练有素的消防员参与；B，那群在疏散后回到地狱镇并决定试图拯救它的朋友们，都是一起长大的，关系非常铁，要么仍然住在地狱镇及周边地区，要么那里有家人。
They're also all in their 40s-- well, one 39-year-old. They all have kids. Very aware of their own mortality. So in early November, around 7:45 at night, Jeb, Jason, and Dharma, son of hippie parents, drove up to the ridge overlooking Helltown and just stood there, staring down, with no plan, just watching flames in the distance. This is Dharma.
他们也都40多岁——嗯，有一个39岁。他们都有孩子。非常意识到自己的死亡率。所以11月初，晚上7:45左右，杰布、杰森和达摩，嬉皮父母的儿子，开车上山，俯瞰地狱镇，站在那里，盯着下方，没有计划，只是盯着远处的火焰。这是达摩。
You know, first, we're in shock. We're a little bit-- we're like, pointing at different spots, thinking that's your home, that's your parents' home. Oh, man-- these little fires are everywhere. And then the fire's coming down these-- all down the ridge, it's coming down all the little creek cracks, coming down the canyon walls.
你知道，起初，我们处于震惊中。我们有点——我们像是，指着不同的点，心想那是你的家，那是你父母的家。哦，天哪——这些小火到处都是。然后火顺着这些——顺着山脊烧下来，顺着所有的小溪流烧下来，顺着峡谷墙壁烧下来。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And it looked like lava flow. It reminded me of just like lava, again, like red waterfalls, coming down the sides of the hills.
看起来像熔岩流。它让我想起就像熔岩，再次，就像红色的瀑布，从山坡上流下来。
It seemed like the right time to turn around and leave, which is exactly what Jeb says, very sensibly, in a cell phone video from that night.
那时候似乎是转身离开的最佳时机，这正是杰布在当晚的一段手机视频里非常理智地说的。
We should leave pretty soon.
我们应该很快离开。
Not once.
不止一次。
Guys, we should go, look at that.
伙计们，我们该走了，看那个。
Not twice.
不止两次。
Yeah, we got to turn around, buddy.
是啊，我们得掉头，伙计。
Three times he says it, agreeing with Jason's brother, who was on the phone, also urging them to get the hell out of there. But as they were looking down, suddenly they noticed tail lights, one car moving fast through Helltown. This is Dharma again.
他说了三次，同意杰森的兄弟（当时正在电话里，也敦促他们赶紧滚蛋）。但当他们向下看时，突然注意到尾灯，一辆车在地狱镇快速移动。这是达摩。
Weaving around, you can kind of follow the tail lights.
转弯，你几乎可以跟着尾灯。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I thought it was this friend of ours, because the way they were driving, we have a friend that we kind of-- that we grew up with, up in the canyon. We thought it was this guy, Little Billy. But--
我以为是我们的一位朋友，因为他们开车的方式，我们有一个朋友，我们算是——一起长大的，在峡谷上。我们以为是这哥们，小比利。但——
Just based on how he was driving?
仅仅是根据他开车的方式？
Yes, because the way someone stops, and then jumps in, and-- yeah, you have to know this guy.
是的，因为某人停车的方式，然后跳进去，然后——是的，你得认识这哥们。
OK, all right.
好的，好吧。
It wasn't Little Billy, though. It was a different guy Jeb, Jason, and Dharma had all grown up with, the trained firefighter, who we're going to call Sam, because he was not officially there.
不过不是小比利。是杰布、杰森和达摩一起长大的另一个人，那位训练有素的消防员，我们叫他萨姆，因为他不是官方在那里的。
The three of them up on the ridge guessed it was Sam, called him on his cell. He said, yep, it's me, I'm down here.
山上这三个人猜是萨姆，在手机上叫他。他说，没错，是我，我在下面。
And I don't want to put words in his mouth, but I'm pretty sure he said, I think Helltown's still standing or something. There's a lot of homes down here that are still doing OK.
我不便替他说话，但我很确定他说，我想地狱镇还立着或者类似的话。下面有很多房子情况还好。
Sam the firefighter also said, I'm not leaving. The fire's not bad here yet. There's spot fires. And I'm going to stay and do what I can. Sam was alone down there. Helltown's volunteer fire department and all of its equipment had been deployed elsewhere.
萨姆这位消防员还说，我不走。这里火势还没那么坏。有些点状火灾。我要留下尽我所能。萨姆在下面孤身一人。地狱镇的志愿消防部门及其所有设备都被调往别处。
Then that was like the three of us kind of looked at each other, and, you know, we made the decision, we're going to drive down there and help Sam out.
然后就像我们三个互相看了看，你知道，我们做了决定，我们要开车下去帮萨姆。
Did it feel like, OK, he's down there, this is doable, and we're just going to do it? Or did it feel like, this might be crazy?
感觉像是，好的，他在下面，这是可行的，我们要干了吗？还是感觉，这可能很疯狂？
I'm going to say D, all the above.
我想说D，以上皆是。
OK.
好的。
It was a little bit-- a little bit of everything, yes.
这有点——有点各方面原因，是的。
Fire doesn't always move in an organized way. Even an enormous wildfire like this isn't just one mass, spreading out like a flood. Bits of fire jump off, embers fly out or get picked up by the wind. And if those embers land, spot fires can start up, little hot spots that could become huge new fires or-- or they could fizzle if there isn't stuff around to burn.
火灾并不总是以有组织的方式移动。即使是像这样巨大的野火，也不仅仅是一个整体，像洪水一样蔓延。火星跳出来，灰烬飞出或被风卷走。如果这些灰烬落下，可能会引发点状火灾，这些小热点可能会变成巨大的新火灾，或者如果周围没有可燃物，它们可能会熄灭。
Fire has needs and weaknesses that can be exploited if you're skilled and very, very lucky. Dharma describes himself as an old athlete, pedal to the metal, go for it person. Whereas, Jeb is an artist, more of a quiet, let's think about this, perspective having person. So, the whole breakfast club mix of the four people is athlete, artist, firefighter, and Jason.
火有需求和弱点，如果你技术娴熟且非常非常幸运，是可以利用的。达摩形容自己是个老运动员，油门到底，冲就对了的人。而杰布是艺术家，更安静，让我们思考一下，有透视感的人。所以，四个人的早餐俱乐部组合是运动员、艺术家、消防员和杰森。
Jason didn't want to be interviewed. The firefighter was busy. So this is Jeb and Dharma's story of that night, starting with the harry drive downhill in poor Jason's new truck, down a skinny dirt road, called Center Gap Road, that skirts along the canyon. And they're heading into flames.
杰森不想接受采访。消防员很忙。所以这是杰布和达摩当晚的故事，从那辆可怜的杰森新卡车上的惊险下坡路开始，沿着一条被称为中央缺口路的窄土路，沿着峡谷边缘行驶。他们正冲向火焰。
Sure enough, about halfway down the road, the fire was on both sides of Center Gap. Feels like we're driving-- we're on one of those little space shuttles or things, and we're driving on planet Mars. You know, everything's burning all around you. It's like everything's on fire.
果然，半路，两边都是火。感觉我们在开车——我们在某种小太空梭或类似东西上，我们在火星上。你知道，周围一切都在燃烧。就像一切都着火了。
Here's Jeb's quiet artist version of that drive.
这是杰布安静的艺术家版本。
We did drive-through some flames to get down that road, but nothing like life threatening.
我们确实穿过了一些火焰才走下那条路，但没什么生命危险。
OK. I'll take your word for it, OK.
好的。我信你的话，好的。
Jeb, Dharma, and Jason get down to the main drag, Centerville Road, and they're looking around. And Sam is right, a lot of houses are still standing. And Centerville Road is a natural fire stop. The big fire is moving unevenly down the canyon on the right. And most of Helltown's houses are to the left of Centerville Road, the side away from the fire. And then, here and there are spot fires, one of which Sam is hacking away at.
杰布、达摩和杰森下到主道森特维尔路，环顾四周。萨姆说得对，很多房子还立着。森特维尔路是一个天然的防火带。大火在右边的峡谷里不均匀地移动。地狱镇大部分房子都在森特维尔路左侧，背离火的一侧。然后，到处都是点状火灾，萨姆正在其中一个地方砍伐。
There was a house and the cedar fence is all on fire. And Sam has a chainsaw. And he's-- he's chainsawing parts of the fence, and kicking them over, trying to-- I see what he was doing. He was stopping it from-- the flames were burning all this whole fence. And they were getting close to the house. And instantly, he's like, there's no time for talk. There's a shovel in the back of my truck.
那里有一栋房子，雪松栅栏都着火了。萨姆手里有电锯。他——他正在用电锯切栅栏的部分，踢开它们，试图——我明白他在做什么。他在阻止火势——火焰正在烧毁整个栅栏。它们正接近房子。他立刻就像，没时间说话。我卡车后斗里有把铲子。
He's just shouting this at you?
他冲着你们喊？
Yeah.
是的。
Over the chainsaw.
隔着电锯声。
Yeah, over the chainsaw. He's like get to work, you made it.
是的，隔着电锯声。他说干活，既然你们来了。
The escape plan, if it came to that, was meet under the bridge and jump in the creek. Sam also gave some quick tips-- check overhead to make sure you're not under power lines and always park your truck pointed downhill for a quick getaway. Other than that, it was just fire triage.
如果真到了那一步，逃生计划就是桥下集合跳进小溪。萨姆还给了一些快速建议——检查头顶确保不在电线下，永远把车头朝向坡下以便快速逃离。除此之外，只是火灾分诊。
Patrol up and down Centerville Road, assess where the fire is getting close to the road, and clear as much brush and flammable material as possible away from the side of the road where the fire is approaching. Keep an eye on trees that might burn and fall across the road. And tackle whatever looks most urgent with whatever tool you've got.
在森特维尔路上来回巡逻，评估火势在哪里靠近道路，并尽可能清理路边火势逼近方向的灌木和易燃物。盯着可能着火并倒在路上的树。并用手头任何工具处理看起来最紧急的情况。
For the houses, Jason had an excavator, sort of like a tank with a long bucket arm. He would drop the bucket arm down and drag it around the houses and buildings to clear brush that might catch fire. Basically, make a fire resistant clearing. Also, he could lift the arm up about 20 feet, to break off branches that might catch fire and fall on people's houses.
对于房子，杰森有一台挖掘机，就像一辆带有长斗臂的坦克。他会放下斗臂，拖着它围着房子和建筑，清理可能着火的灌木。基本上，制造一个防火空地。此外，他可以把臂升起约20英尺，打断可能着火并落在人们房子上的树枝。
Dharma and Jeb dug ditches by the road, around houses. They raked brush. They moved propane tanks. They used shovels. They used water, if they could find it, and anything else at hand to put out flaming decks and sheds.
达摩和杰布在路边、房子周围挖沟。他们耙掉灌木。他们移动丙烷罐。他们用铲子。他们用挖掘到的水，如果能找到的话，以及任何手头的东西来扑灭起火的甲板和棚屋。
When they finished with one area, they jumped in one of the two trucks and drove to the next one, up and down the same mile of road. Sam was fighting fires and also coming back and guiding the rest of them-- go here, go there. Around 9 PM, pretty early on, they all lost cell phone service.
当他们清理完一个区域，就跳上一辆卡车开往下一个，在同一英里路上来回跑。萨姆在灭火，也回来引导其他人——去这儿，去那儿。9点左右，很早的时候，他们都失去了手机服务。
So we would all check in with each other, and go, hey, how you doing, what do you need?
我们会互相核对，说，嘿，你好吗，你需要什么？
Yeah.
是的。
We're going here to look at this spot.
我们要去这里看看这个点。
We were mostly worried about where the pine trees were at.
我们主要担心松树在哪里。
He means the trees on the side of the canyon.
他指的是峡谷边的树。
Because they're the ones that kick off the big embers and have the sap that kind of explodes.
因为它们是那些喷射出大灰烬的树，树液会爆炸。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And then the flames were coming over in different spots everywhere, right? All the way down the canyon, it's kind of falling over. And there was a couple of trees that were kind of hanging over, up by the Centerville Cemetery.
然后火焰在各个地方跳跃，对吧？整条峡谷，它就像倒下来了。森特维尔墓地那边有几棵树悬着。
There was kind of like a-- it's like a tunnel up there of big oaks. And I was a little concerned that the fire would hit those, and crawl up in there, and then kind of cross over the road.
那边就像一个——橡树隧道。我有点担心火会烧到那些树，钻进去，然后横跨道路。
All night, they were clearing small flammable things away from bigger, more dangerous flammable things, obsessively crushing out little fires.
整晚，他们都在把小的易燃物从更大更危险的易燃物中清理出来，痴迷地扑灭小火。
I was stamping on coals and burning leaves. And I realized, I can't do this anymore. So I grabbed one of my kayak paddles. And I was slapping flames with a kayak paddle.
我踩着余烬和燃烧的叶子。我意识到，我干不动了。所以我拿了我的皮划艇桨。我用皮划艇桨拍打火焰。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
To put them out.
来扑灭它们。
You couldn't do it, cause-- cause your shoes were not standing up. Your shoes were--
你没法做，因为——因为你的鞋子撑不住。你的鞋子——
My legs were so sore.
我的腿太疼了。
Oh.
哦。
No, my legs were sore.
不，我的腿疼。
Oh, your legs were sore. The shoes were holding up, but your legs were sore. Oh, my god, wow.
哦，你的腿疼。鞋子撑住了，但腿疼。哦，天哪，哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
My boots did melt. The soles of my boots were completely melted, partially because there was a tree that was on fire that was going to fall onto my house. So I was cutting it with a chainsaw to drop it, so it wouldn't fall the other direction.
我的靴子化了。靴底完全化了，部分原因是因为有一棵着火的树要倒在我房子上。所以我用电锯锯它，让它掉向另一个方向。
And then I got to a point where it was almost about to fall, and I just said, you know what, this is not really safe. I'm standing in hot coals. And I've got a chainsaw, and I'm by myself, so-- under a tree that's on fire. So, I'm like, this is probably not the best idea. So, I just let it be.
后来我锯到快要倒的地方，我就说，你知道吗，这真不安全。我站在热炭上。我拿着电锯，我一个人，所以——在着火的树下。所以，我想，这大概不是个好主意。所以，我就没管它。
Were there moments that were actually-- where you were frightened?
有没有那一刻——你感到害怕？
Yes. I would say up by Jeb's house, watching it kind of-- the flames around Jeb's place were real-- were pretty-- were pretty intense. And they were really like-- I remember the-- I remember looking up at 60-- 60 foot flames, or 40, 50 foot flames, and just going, wow. And just hearing, and seeing the fire, the intenseness of fire.
有。我会说在杰布房子那边，看着它——杰布房子周围的火焰真的——真的很强烈。它们真的就像——我记得看着60——60英尺的火焰，或者40、50英尺的火焰，然后只是哇。只是听到，看到火，火的强度。
We were buying time. We were holding the fire back until the professionals got there, so we were hoping. But we were hoping as soon as possible that someone would be there with some engines. I mean, that's all I wanted to hear, was a helicopter or a fire engine.
我们在争取时间。我们在拖延火势直到专业人员赶到，我们这么希望着。但我们希望尽快有人带着引擎赶到。我是说，我只想听到直升机或消防车的声音。
Without cell phone service, they had no idea why no one was coming, hour after hour. This was the first day of the fire. They didn't know how bad it was going to get and how bad it already was.
没有手机服务，他们不知道为什么几个小时过去了还没人来。这是火灾的第一天。他们不知道火势会变得多糟糕，以及已经有多糟糕。
Is there anybody out there? I mean, we really felt like we were the only ones on the planet Earth at that point. And it was like, where's the help? Are we the only ones out here? You know, we're the only ones. Like where's everybody at?
外面还有人吗？我是说，我们真的感觉就像那个时刻地球上唯一活着的人。就像，救援在哪？我们是这里仅存的人吗？你知道，我们是仅有的。就像所有人都在哪？
The fight did not feel heroic at any point. It was a slog. They kept the fire away from as many buildings and houses as they could along that mile or so stretch of road. But they were never done. Some places had to be saved again and again.
这战斗在任何时候都不觉得英雄。这很沉重。他们把火挡在了那一英里左右路段的尽可能多的建筑和房子外。但他们永远做不完。有些地方必须一而再再而三地扑救。
Jeb's house was one of the few that was on the other side of the road, the side the fire was coming from. So, no road between his house and the fire. Jeb and Dharma would go to his house, fight the fire down, go tackle someplace else, come back to make sure the place was OK, and have to fight the fire down all over again.
杰布的房子是路另一边极少数几栋房子之一，火势逼近的那边。所以，他房子和火之间没有路。杰布和达摩会去他家灭火，去别处处理，再回来确保房子没事，又得再灭一遍。
Dharma's adrenaline wore off around 3:30 in the morning, after 7 and 1/2 hours of non-stop physical labor. He was crashing and his legs were seizing up. He and Jason went to Jason's house, which Sam had declared safe for the moment.
凌晨3:30，在连续7个半小时不停的体力劳动后，达摩的肾上腺素消退了。他崩溃了，腿在抽筋。他和杰森去了萨姆宣布目前安全的杰森家。
I just had to put-- stretch my feet out for a second. That was the first time I got to get off my feet. And we ended up sitting on his couch for a few minutes, where we sort of dozed off for a second or so.
我不得不——把脚伸直一会儿。这是我第一次让脚休息。我们最后在那沙发上坐了几分钟，然后稍微打了个盹。
Jeb was frantically awake. He was up at his house, whack-a-moling fires, that over the course of the night went 360 degrees around his house.
杰布惊慌地醒着。他在他家，一直忙着扑火，整晚火势绕着他家烧了360度。
Were you mad that they wanted to sleep?
你生气他们想睡觉吗？
No, not really. I knew that we were all exhausted. But I just told them, I can't-- there's no way that I can go to sleep. So, they were like, we'll be back in an hour. By this time, two hours passed, and I was like, really guys, like--
不，不完全是。我知道我们都精疲力竭了。但我只是告诉他们，我不能——我没法去睡觉。所以，他们就像，我们一小时后回来。这时候已经过了两小时，我就像，真的吗伙计们，像——
Oh.
哦。
At one point, I had Jason's truck, and I was by myself. And I pointed it down the driveway, and had engine idling, and I was just yelling into the air, like where is our help? I think there's a few other words that I won't say that were involved in that.
有一次，我开着杰森的卡车，我一个人。我把车头指向车道，怠速发动引擎，我只是对着空气大喊，我们的救援在哪？我想还有几个我不便说的词也包括在内。
Later, in the weeks and months after the fire, this is the scene and feeling that Jeb kept dreaming about, fighting the fire at his house alone. The way Jeb and Dharma described the night, with the smoke blowing through, and this eerie warmth in the air, when it should have been chilly, because it was November, it sounded lonely in some core way, like every person, every creature in the canyon, was having its own personal battle with this thing.
后来，在大火过后的几周和几个月里，这是杰布一直梦到的场景和感觉，独自在房子里灭火。杰布和达摩描述当晚的方式，烟雾飘过，空气中有种诡异的温暖（尽管是11月，本该凉爽的），这听起来核心处很孤独，就像峡谷里的每个人、每个生物，都在进行着与这场灾难的个人战斗。
I saw this huge bear come running out of one of the little driveways. And he saw me and he ran right into the fire.
我看到这头巨大的熊从车道里跑出来。它看到我，就跑进了火里。
Oh, Jesus.
哦，上帝。
Because I was driving towards him. The wildlife was freaking out. I saw a couple of deer with singed fur, and they just didn't know what to do. There was this little mouse at one point, that kept running towards the flames, and we would stop him and put him on the other side of the road. And he kept running back towards the flames. We're like, wait, guy, you're going the wrong way.
因为我正朝它开过去。野生动物都疯了。我看到几只毛被烧焦的鹿，它们完全不知道该怎么办。当时有只小老鼠，一直往火焰方向跑，我们会挡住它并把它放在路的那边。它还是往火里跑。我们想，嘿，伙计，你跑错方向了。
Finally, finally, around 11:00 AM, some friends from the area showed up with burritos and water.
终于，终于，早上11点左右，附近的一些朋友带着墨西哥卷饼和水出现了。
And I remember sitting on the side of the road, and I'm eating a little burrito. And then here comes, through the smoke-- I looked down, and through the smoke comes the fire department.
我记得坐在路边，吃着小卷饼。然后这里过来了，穿过烟雾——我向下看，穿过烟雾消防队来了。
An out of town fire truck comes ripping through the smoke. And it was like, we hold our shovels up. We're like help has arrived. And I remember, like-- and the firefighters, they come up to us. And they stop their truck, you know, and the guy looks out the window. And I go-- I'm like, hey, man, there's a lot of homes up here. I'm glad you guys finally made it.
一辆外地的消防车穿过烟雾呼啸而至。就像，我们举起铲子。我们就像救援到了。我记得，就像——消防员走近我们。他们停下车，你知道，那个人看着窗外。我像——我说，嘿，伙计，这里有很多房子。很高兴你们终于到了。
And I'm thinking he's going to be like, right on, guys, great job. He's like this is dangerous, what are you doing? You need to get out of here. And then he-- and drives off. So, we didn't get no welcome there. He was like, nah. He was like, you guys-- we're civilians, we weren't supposed to be there.
我在想他会说，太棒了伙计们，干得好。他说这很危险，你们在干什么？你们得离开这。然后他——开走了。所以，我们没得到欢迎。他就像，不。他就像，你们这些——我们是平民，我们不该在那儿。
Yeah.
是啊。
That was I think their take. And it was pretty dangerous, so--
我想那是他们的想法。这确实很危险，所以——
On that night, they must have been-- I mean, they probably had just come through some really harrowing sights.
那天晚上，他们肯定——我是说，他们大概刚刚经历了非常令人揪心的场面。
They really did. I mean, and then, because like, hours later, it was 2 or 3 o'clock in the afternoon, Jeb and I finally got-- we got a ride out. We were like pretty much delusional and tired. And we got a ride out of the canyon. And we saw the total devastation.
他们确实经历了。我是说，然后，因为就像，几小时后，下午2或3点，杰布和我终于得到——我们搭了车出来。我们几乎是神志不清且疲惫。我们搭车离开峡谷。我们看到了彻底的破坏。
We were in the country club, compared to the front lines, yeah. Yeah, it was definitely a realization of like, oh, I know why no one was here. You couldn't even get up here. And there was much more important places to be, and lives to save, you know.
相比前线，我们在乡村俱乐部，是的。是的，这绝对是一种意识到，哦，我知道为什么这里没人。你根本进不来。还有更重要的地方要去，生命要去拯救，你知道。
But you don't think about that when you're in the moment of your own little bubble of your own neighborhood, you know.
但当你身处于你自己小社区的泡泡里时，你不会考虑那些。
Yeah.
是啊。
What's going on everywhere else.
其他地方发生了什么。
Helltown is less than four miles from Paradise, which burned to the ground. Jeb and Dharma spent the whole exhausting night imagining, guessing, that they'd been overlooked. When they drove out, they saw the truth. They hadn't been overlooked. They'd been spared.
地狱镇离天堂镇不到四英里，天堂镇烧成了平地。杰布和达摩在整晚精疲力竭的猜测中，以为他们被忽略了。当他们开车出来时，他们看到了真相。他们没有被忽略。他们是被幸免了。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. It took firefighters another two-plus days to fully save Helltown. In the end, according to Dharma, only two houses were lost in the area of the canyon around Helltown. Again, we heard about Helltown from Robert Baird's great story in GQ. It's going to be in the May issue of the magazine. And you can read it on the internet right now, online, at GQ.com.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。消防员又用了两天多时间才完全救下地狱镇。最后，根据达摩的说法，地狱镇周围的峡谷地区只有两栋房子损失了。再次，我们是从罗伯特·贝尔德在《智族GQ》的精彩故事中听说了地狱镇。它将刊登在五月刊杂志上。你现在可以在网上GQ.com阅读。
Act Three, The Book of Death is Long and Boring. So our show today is about being left behind when loved ones leave. And we'll close out our show with this, about the way people disappear all the time, and the place they go to when they're gone. David Kestenbaum explains.
第三幕，死亡之书既漫长又乏味。所以我们今天的节目是关于当亲人离开时被留下的感觉。我们将以这个故事结束节目，关于人们总是消失的方式，以及他们离开后去的地方。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆来解释。
Imagine there was a book containing all the names of the dead, all the people who had lived, an enormous book, the last pages of which are blank. A half second passes, and a new name appears in the book, then another name, another name.
想象有一本书，包含所有死者的名字，所有曾经生活过的人，一本巨大的书，最后一页是空白的。半秒钟过去，一个新名字出现在书里，然后另一个名字，另一个。
Actually, imagine the book had their Social Security numbers too. Because it does.
其实，想象一下这本书里还有他们的社会保障号码。因为确实有。
The Death Master File.
死亡主文件。
It's quite a name.
真是个名字。
It is quite a name, yes.
真是个名字，是的。
The Death Master File.
死亡主文件。
It sounds a little like Star Wars or something, you know.
听起来有点像《星球大战》之类的，你知道。
It sounds like a book from the afterlife.
听起来像是来世的一本书。
Yes.
是的。
Mike Astrue used to be responsible for the Death Master File, and a whole bunch of other stuff. The Death Master File, to be clear, is not a book. It's just a computer file. The people who maintain it work in a building just outside of Baltimore. It's the headquarters of the Social Security Administration, which Astrue was the commissioner of for six years, under President Bush, and then Obama. The government started keeping track of the deaths in 1936. It began as paper records.
迈克·阿斯特鲁曾负责死亡主文件，以及一堆其他事情。明确一下，死亡主文件不是书。它只是一个电脑文件。维护它的人在巴尔的摩郊外的一栋大楼里工作。那是社会保障管理局的总部，阿斯特鲁曾在布什政府下，后来在奥巴马政府下担任局长六年。政府从1936年开始追踪死亡人数。最初是纸质记录。
You know, it was just part of the wiring of the building. And nobody really thought about it. There would have been almost no one outside the agency, probably, that even knew that this existed.
你知道，它只是建筑接线的一部分。没人真正想到它。机构外几乎没人知道它的存在。
Some of the first names on the list, William M Gamble of Louisiana, Eson Bailey, West Virginia, Sidor Mullinar, Connecticut. They all died in 1936, which was the first year Social Security cards were issued, meaning they would have only had their numbers for a month or so before they died. William Gambles was 435-03-3049.
名单上的前几个名字，路易斯安那州的威廉·M·甘布尔，西弗吉尼亚州的埃森·贝利，康涅狄格州的西多·穆利纳尔。他们都死于1936年，那是社会保障卡发行的第一年，意味着他们拿到号码只有一个月左右就死了。威廉·甘布尔的是435-03-3049。
How many names do you think are on it now?
你认为现在上面有多少名字？
It's probably, right now, in the range of about 100 million names.
现在，大概在1亿个名字左右。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
It was a creation of pure bureaucracy. We track births, we should track deaths. They are symmetrical events. But of course, the feelings associated with each couldn't be more different. The Death Master File became available to the public in 1980. Companies used it to detect fraud, to see if someone was trying to use a dead person's Social Security number. Anyway, one day Mike was at home and the phone rang.
它是纯官僚主义的产物。我们追踪出生，我们也应该追踪死亡。它们是对称的事件。但当然，与每件事相关的感受截然不同。死亡主文件在1980年对公众开放。公司用它来侦测欺诈，看看是否有人试图使用死者的社会保障号码。总之，有一天迈克在家，电话响了。
One of my best friends in the world came to me, very sheepishly. And very careful to say, you know, don't do anything that legally and ethically you're not allowed to do. But my mother is upset that her father is not in the Death Master File.
我最好的朋友之一非常羞涩地找到我。并且非常小心地说，你知道，别做任何你在法律和伦理上不允许做的事。但我母亲很不高兴她父亲不在死亡主文件中。
She'd been tracing out the family's history. And one resource people use to do that is the Death Master File. And somehow in that long list of millions of names, her father wasn't in there, which is not surprising. It's actually kind of tricky to know of everyone who dies. Someone has to notify the state where the person died.
她一直在追踪家族历史。人们用来做那件事的一个资源是死亡主文件。不知何故，在那个数百万名字的长名单里，她父亲不在那儿，这并不令人惊讶。实际上要知道每个死者是谁其实挺棘手的。必须有人通知死者所在的州。
Then the state has to submit the information to the federal government. And you know, states. But Mike had never heard of anyone complaining about not being on the list. He told his friend, let me see what I can do. And when he got to work-- remember, he was head of Social Security-- he went to talk to the people who actually managed the Death Master File.
然后州必须向联邦政府提交信息。你知道的，州政府。但迈克从未听说过有人抱怨没在名单上。他告诉朋友，我看看能做什么。当他上班时——记住，他是社保局局长——他去和真正管理死亡主文件的人交谈。
I went down and talked to them. And they were puzzled, because first of all, no one had ever asked. And they did have the response-- well, you know, usually people are trying to get off the list, because the agency does accidentally declare a certain number of people dead who are not dead. And they're usually quite upset about that.
我下去和他们谈了。他们很困惑，因为首先，从来没人问过。他们确实有个回应——嗯，你知道，通常人们都在努力从名单上脱离，因为机构确实会不小心宣布某些活着的人已经死亡。他们通常为此感到非常愤怒。
Because all of a sudden, their credit cards don't work, or their ATM card. It's kind of a powerful list. The staff was used to taking people off the list. They had a term for that-- to undead, as in, he'll be undeaded by Friday, or we can't undead her without her Social Security number. In the end, it wasn't hard. If you can undead someone, you can certainly dead them. They deaded his friend's grandfather. Mike told his friend, who told his mom.
因为突然间，他们的信用卡不能用了，或者ATM卡。这是一个功能强大的名单。工作人员习惯于把人从名单上除名。他们有一个术语叫“除死”（undead），比如，他会在周五被除死，或者没有他的社会保障号码我们无法除死她。最后，这并不难。如果你能让某人“除死”，你当然能让他“死”。他们处理了他朋友的祖父。迈克告诉了朋友，朋友告诉了母亲。
So what my friend told me was that it had been a very emotional moment when she realized that her father was in the Death Master File. And you know, and I got a very grateful, emotional letter from her.
所以我朋友告诉我，当她意识到她父亲在死亡主文件中时，那是一个非常感性的时刻。而且你知道，我收到了她一封非常感激、感性的信。
It's like, she just wanted him, like in that small way, not to be left out.
就像，她只是想让他，以那种微小的方式，不要被遗忘。
Yes, burial of the dead is important.
是的，埋葬死者很重要。
What did it feel like to know that somebody felt that way about it? Like, when you were walking down the hall, you must have been like, oh, I never thought about this thing that way.
知道有人对这件事有这种感觉是什么感觉？比如，当你走在走廊时，你一定在想，哦，我从没那样想过这件事。
I think that the-- this particular story didn't really change my emotional connection to the Death Master File. But I understand it, and I respect it.
我觉得这个特定故事并没有真正改变我与死亡主文件的情感连接。但我理解它，我尊重它。
When someone dies, they leave us behind. But we're also leaving them behind. It's natural to want some kind of marker. I think if you're going to collect the names of the dead, millions after millions of names, and then call that thing the Death Master File, it's more than just a government record. People are going to have feelings about it.
当某人去世时，他们留下我们。但我们也留下了他们。想要某种标记是很自然的。我认为如果你要收集数百万死者的名字，然后把那个东西叫死亡主文件，这不仅仅是一个政府记录。人们会对它有感觉。
It is kind of hard for me not to imagine the moment when my name gets added, you know. Like, there's a moment, it's going to happen, and then there will be another name right behind it, and then another, you know.
很难不想象我的名字被加入的那一刻，你知道。就像，会有那一刻，它会发生，然后会有另一个名字紧随其后，然后另一个，你知道。
I guess. I guess that's right. I-- for whatever reason, I'm sort of immune to that feeling.
我想。我想那是对的。我——因为某种原因，我对那种感觉免疫。
Which, of course, is the ridiculous and remarkable thing about all of us. You can know about this list, maybe you're even the boss of it. And you can manage not to think about it at all.
这当然是我们所有人的荒谬且非凡之处。你可以知道这个名单，也许你甚至是它的老板。而你竟然能管理到完全不想这件事。
David Kestenbaum is one of the producers of our show.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put our show together includes Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, and Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hillary Elkins, Jared Floyd, Damian Grave, Seth Lind, Mike Meek, Lena Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katharine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目由莉莉·沙利文制作。参与节目策划的人包括艾尔娜·贝克、本·卡尔洪、佐伊·蔡斯和奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、希拉里·埃尔金斯、杰瑞德·弗洛伊德、达米安·格雷夫、塞斯·林德、迈克·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和戴安·吴。我们的执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Kathy Hinckley, to Stephanie Teatro and the Tennessee Immigrant and Refugee Rights Coalition, to KC Curberson-Alvarado, Liz Neill, Robert Neill, Jackson Neill, Jonathan Burrello, Shira Rubin, Joseph Feit, Jeremy Feit, Negusi Alamu, Susan Pollack, Aster Yilma, Degu Abunie, Cassie Greene O'Hara, Kelefa Sanneh, and Sara Bohannon.
今天特别感谢凯西·欣克利、斯蒂芬妮·泰特罗和田纳西移民与难民权利联盟，感谢KC·库伯森-阿尔瓦拉多、莉兹·尼尔、罗伯特·尼尔、杰克逊·尼尔、乔纳森·布雷洛、希拉·鲁宾、约瑟夫·费特、杰里米·费特、内古西·阿拉穆、苏珊·波拉克、阿斯特·伊尔马、德古·阿布尼、卡西·格林·奥哈拉、凯莱法·桑内和莎拉·博汉农。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 670 episodes for absolutely free. Or you can download all those episodes, using the This American Life app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费在线流媒体播放我们超过670集的档案。或者你可以使用《美国生活》应用下载所有剧集。本节目由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he really is a bit of a name dropper. His car broke down this week, I believe at a friend's house. And told me--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他确实有点喜欢拿名字来抬高自己。他这周车坏了，我相信是在一个朋友家。然后告诉我——
Like a garage of the Kennedys is probably better than most.
像肯尼迪家的车库大概比大多数人的都好。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。